Nói chẳng mặt hồ điều qua công viên CV1 mục mũi khó chịu công dân phải lịch tục thu gòn.
Hãy ngày qua, hồ điều qua trong công viên CV1 xuất hiện gà chết hàng loạt sau đợt nặng gẩy khách.
Cá suốt phi, chép và gà mẹ, nổi dây đặc vên hồ kéo dài khoảng 20 mết.
Gần sau mấy công dân của sĩ nghiệp 8 nước số 2 hà nội được quy đậu thu gòn,
lặng bào và vận chuyện gà chết đến khu sự lý rất thải án sơn.
Mắn ngống cực đạc cực đạc.
Giải ngày sau đó sẽ sẽ gà đấm người tự nối lớn ở nổ điều qua.
I mà nó nước vừa vào thì cái thay lội như đội nên hồ của hiện tập cá chết.
Tính chờ đấy từ xa nghe là thì ở nổ phà hồn mời tấn.
Bồ điều phà dụng người chỉ đi tà thuộc phương câu dễ đưa phà phạt đậu thu dầu năm 2020.